protesters are digging themselves in
erecting barricades and preparing for
confrontation
police have started to cordon off
Lucerne the last remaining Village on
the edge of the garsweiler mine one of
Germany's largest lignite mines in the
country's most industrialized region
lignite or brown coal is known to be one
of the most polluting forms of coal and
under Luther lies millions of tons of it
the government says it needs the coal to
prevent energy shortages activists say
it violates their climate policies it
looks good on paper right that Germany
is Gonna Leave coal by 2030 actually
it's only the west of Germany up until
now but the thing is at the same time
they said okay we're going to keep more
coal power plants running now that they
were going to phase out by now so
actually we're just gonna burn the same
amount or even more coal in shorter time
which is even worse for the climate
climate activists from all over Europe
travel to lutsunra to protest against
the expansion people from all
generations called on the government to
change its mind
while the original villagers have left
dozens of activists have moved to
lutsenrad and built three houses a tiny
village that has turned into an
international protest site with hundreds
of activists saying they won't follow
police orders and leave a standoff that
could possibly turn violent but also
become an embarrassment for the
government and its promises to abide by
the Paris agreement
climate activists like Johanna inkerman
say the expansion of the mind will mean
the 1.5 degree temperature rise globally
agreed in Paris won't be feasible that's
a single room
that's why she moved to lutzenrad months
ago now is the moment to defend this
Village and to defend climate Justice if
we wouldn't stay here this Machinery of
Destruction that we see just a couple
meters behind us would have already
raised all this to the ground
the activists are disappointed with the
greens who first supported their cause
and are now in government responsible
for the expansion the Energy company rwe
who owns the mine and the authorities in
North Rhine West Valley are declined or
requests to comment
the eviction of lutzenrad is expected to
start in the next few days unless
protesters can hold their ground and
manage to stop it stop fasten Al Jazeera
in Little Rock